vous comprenez béatrice évidemment que
je comprends c'est scandaleux envoyer un
bon d'achat de 20 euros pour la vie d'un
enfant c'est c'est vraiment hyper chaud
quand même s'ils vont dire que c'est ça
a été fait automatiquement que c'est une
erreur etc il devrait quand même y avoir
des contrôles ils savent qu'il ya eu un
énorme scandale voilà moi
personnellement c'est vrai que je
comprends qu'ils aient un manque de
confiance dorénavant et
donc on met 15 buts à gilles bouleau
tina oui parce qu'il faut que ça cesse
alors je sais vous allez me dire des
gens risquent d'être au chômage il faut
boycotter par solidarité avec les
familles il faut boycotter pour faire un
exemple dans ces grandes marques qui ne
respectent pas toutes les inspections le
montrent les protocoles sanitaires et
enfin ne soyez pas naïfs le fait
d'envoyer comme ça des bons d'achat
c'est pour faire taire les familles sait
jamais
c'est pour faire taire les gens leurs
nombreuses 20 euros puis 200 pi demi je
connais ça par coeur donc du coup bien
sûr qu'il faut boycotter même si des
emplois sont en cause il faut faire un
symbole du rallye évidemment que c'est
un scandale et évidemment qu'on est
vraiment choqué et c'est dégueulasse en
plus y'a deux décès mais il ya aussi des
enfants dans un état végétatif l'église
séquelles irrémédiables et c'est
vraiment dramatique mais après on peut
pas sanctionner les salariés lui tony je
pense qu'il faut une enquête moi je suis
allé je suis allé voir un petit peu
comment ça se passait dans l' usine chez
but tony vous sortez avec vos chaussures
pour aller fumer vous revenez avec les
gens ne se lave pas les mains ils ont
sacrifié les règles d'hygiène pour
produire produire produire pendant la
crise du confinement et duco vide il ya
eu encore plus une explosion des ses
pizzas là parce que c'est des produits
surgelés les gens en ont consommé de
plus en plus il y avait un manque de
personnel un manque d'hygiène on avait
le temps de rien donc voilà ça fait des
années qu'on sait qu'il va y avoir un
pépin donc il faut évidemment
sanctionner le directeur de cette usine
là en particulier qui a une enquête qui
est un procès qui évidemment des
dédommagements on peut pas condamner
toute une émission surprise c'est bien
joli de le dire comme ça mais vous savez
très bien que vous même vous n'allez pas
donner à votre enfant vous n'avez pas
acheté ça
on
va mettre des milliers de gens entrent
évidemment la gestion de la crise des
catastrophiques et après on ne doute pas
boycotter la marque parce que déjà ça va
mettre des milliers de personnes au
chômage et puis il y aura aussi des
victimes collatérales c'est tout un
secteur qui va être sanctionné parce que
quand il agit en dalle comme ça avec des
conséquences humaines assure les gens
ont tendance à tout boycotter but tony
et les autres marques qui n'ont rien à
voir dans cette affaire donc ça va
mettre les centaines de salariés
j'aimerais milliers de salariés au
chômage mais ceux d'autres marques et
injustement en revanche la société doit
gérer la crise communiquer expliquer ce
scandale et après peut-être reprendre
une activité trop mal en pas naïf parce
que de toute façon est ce que toi demain
tu vas aller acheter une pizza buitoni
mois dans le doute même si je la
boycotte pas parce que je ne vais pas
faire la claque machin dans le doute
j'ai un enfant de 20 ans je vais pas je
vais pas lui et lui acheter la pizza
bettoni pour l'instant c'est moi moi
j'aime bien ces séries sont les
responsables on attendait sous pression
par la passe qui se passe là et ce qui
va se passer encore c'est que les
responsables ce sont les patrons lui
c'est bien ca c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
ce qu'ils vont trinquer gilles verdez
avec votre solution là si ce sont les
salariés voilà des débuts tony m'a qui
ont la pause décalé
de nettoyage normalement ils mettent des
détergents ils doivent les laisser 20
minutes il est laid cinq minutes
toujours les cadences à super pro du
comité de ça et c'est ça le problème
c'est le responsable responsables ce
sont les patrons se sent pas les
salariés qui aurait cru que les ordres
ont fait naître les les principaux
perdants d'amende- de ce qui s'est passé
et c'est ça que c'est ça qui est grave
oui mais à vous écouter à écouter
guillon mais on ne fait rien à vous
adapter à exécution ici tout le monde en
syrie les tirs et l'inspection des 22 et
29 mars sur le site avec l'aval de la
direction du groupe nestlé ces niveaux
des grades et de la maîtrise de
l'hygiène présence de rongeurs danger
pour le consommateur est d'ailleurs
l'anc est drôle c'est sain et d'ailleurs
et cyril d'ailleurs lé enquête a été
menée dans les usines mais la
perquisition
elle a aussi eu lieu à issy les
moulineaux signe au siège de nestlé
parce qu'ils soupçonnent qui est d
instruction où ils soupçonnent que si
les usines soient si dégradée c'est
parce qu'il ya des économies à faire
parler
ça il en laisse et on le sait très bien
a sanctionné vous enfoncer les portes
ouvertes non je vous donne les éléments
de l'enquète donc il faut son look c'est
mathieu et oui c'est comme si comme les
états qui vont maintenant c'est que les
têtes tombent mais au pénal est très
alarmant les patrons ceux qui organisent
la manière dont 10 pour des questions
d'économie appelé au boycott sas à rien
on a marqué les déjà me connais les
thèmes en octobre économiquement la
marque ne plus acheter s'ils continuent
à faire des bénéfices les têtes ne
tomberont pas tomber les gens qui sont
responsables justement et au pénal tu as
tu n'as pas ton temps à la justice après
tu lui proposes
à part peut-être cinq ans mais si au
final tu sais si aussi au final match du
tonnerre moi je pense d'abord aux
salariés et aux gens qui ont des
familles et qui vont se retrouver
d'organiser facilement ce parce que eux
ils n'auront pas quoi se retourner les
départements d'ille tony ils auront de
quoi se retourner et mans mais voilà mes
oeufs à 10 ans reculait à la crise
allait absolument désastreuse départ et
vers une des mamans racontent et c'est
son avocat qui me portent la voix de
cette maman elle dit que notamment on
l'a appelé en lui posant des questions
qu'elle avait évidemment la tête à autre
chose c'était l'entreprise qui l'a
appelé et que en gros ils sont finis par
eau avec des robes voilà vingt des
circonvolutions à la fin de la
conversation lui dire lui demander
d'avoir accès au dossier médical de sa
fille et en fait on se demande il a
raison gilles pourquoi est ce qu'ils
veulent avoir accès au dossier médical
de l'afld delà de la petite pour essayer
de discréditer de dire il n'y a pas de
lien entre la pizza et mais le lien
cyril moi quand j'ai été victime à
furiani du stade au début on vous
propose une indemnisation on vous dit
prenez 500 euros prenez 1000 euros
prenaient 2000 euros prenez cinq mille
euros c'est pour vous faire taire les
bons cadeaux c'est une manière de faire
taire mais on me donne faim et l'homme
après ça des deux villes comics
entièrement et voyons si mon père est né
de ces formulaires famille n'aille pas
en justice ou le moins possible et vous
vous n'aimez pas ces principes trafford
et impotent faisait pas tout vous
dévoiler vos cadeaux et pour les gens
pour ramener le débat n'est ni ne
connaissez pas les stratégies de
communication de crise de ses maris si
et si vous ne les boycotter pas rien ne
va bouger déjà dans ces immenses et
mandarines et daniela la mère si tu
craques code qu'est ce qui va se passer
durant une bénéfice est sciemment de
bénéfices qui veulent virer les salariés
l'usiné doit frôler
l usine elle est fermée elle doit fermer
définitivement cette saisine donc hélas
à cause des patrons des salariés vont se
retrouver au charme et à côté
consommateurs il vaut mieux il vaut
mieux qu'ils prennent l'argent qu'ils on
voit qu'ils ont fait énormément de
bénéfices surtout pendant la clé du
comité oui qui prennent cet argent pour
remettre le lusine vraiment au bon état
et pour garder les salariés ou les olé
l'avenant l'axé définitivement pas du
tout d'accord avec les élans bêtise
daniel non alors pour le bon d'achat
c'est complètement faux gilles c'est
parti la veille du jour où ils ont
appelé la la maman c'est parti
automatiquement parce qu'elle avait fait
une démarche survenu sur une plate forme
et donc cesser de le timing est très
mauvais ça peut paraître très choquant
évidemment de recevoir un bon d'achat en
plus il y avait quand même marqué bonne
nouvelle sur le web sur leur le courrier
donc c'est horrible pour la maman mais
ça n'a rien à voir avec acheter ou
d'abord on n'achète avec 20 euros et moi
je suis désolé mais il ya un moment où
il faut qu'on fasse notre rôle de
citoyens citoyens ça veut dire qu'on
fait partie de voie l'adq on veut faire
bouger des choses parce qu'il ya cinq
ans lactalis il ya énormément de points
communs tout le monde a crié au scandale
les policiers les policiers excusez moi
les politiques s'en sont émus rien n'a
changé et on se retrouve cinq ans après
et je vous fiche mon billet que dans
cinq ans on parlera d'un autre scandale
donc il ya un moment où il faut oui
montrer notre rôle de citoyens aient
boycotté ces sociétés j'ai cinq six
jours ils sont encore en train ne sort
acheter les uns les autres ils vont
encore faire des profits et voilà donc
alors évidemment toute façon ces grosses
boîtes ne feront jamais et si on montre
quelque chose si on bouge peut-être
contre à bouger à la tête et me
permettre de jean journal que tenait
voiture et le jardin en france ici le
procès vers un procès allez hop au
pureau plus sur la loi 6 mois de prison
et 10000 et 15000 euros d'amendé ça en
est mais que ça arrive c'est passé soit
une amende de 1 million de la secte qui
vont perdre 200 voire 300 voire 400
millions de dollars et là pour le coup
après ça m'a servi de leçon des
souvenirs que c'est effectivement les
actionnaires les grands patrons qu'il
faut qu'il faut sanctionner mais
management en france il ne risque
franchement
moi je vais vous dire moi je veux dire
ce que ce que je vois dans cette
histoire c'est kirk un gagnant c'est
incroyable je vous le dis et si c'était
pour faire plus de profits oui profit
rentabiliser un drame elle etc etc etc
etc est morte cette année ça va être une
catastrophe c'est un drame pour les
salariés cc c'est un drame pour le
groupe voilà le groupe qui dont fait
partie du tony là c'est un truc de fou
pourrait gagner un petit peu plus ils
vont perdre ses pieds noirs donc ça ça
devrait faire réfléchir tous les autres
mais qu'un je vous dirai à tous les
grands groupes là ils doivent se dire
vous avez vu ce qui est arrivé à ce que
la sellette la description le front il
s'en relèveront pas et je vous dire il
va avoir des milliers de deux personnes
au chômage et qui montrent retrouvées
privées contrôlent beaucoup plus
fréquent vraiment ce pont version sans
les prévenir etc il faudrait qu'ils
sachent qu'ils peuvent être contrôlés
nos branches quand on est régulièrement
pour que ça marche on l'a vu dans les
ehpad et ils sont prévenus à l'avancé on
l'a vu dans les abattoirs il n'y a pas
de personnel ça marche pas
parce qu'on a des budgets oui raymond
pour ça bouge il faudrait mettre les
gens devant leurs responsabilités
c'est-à-dire les directeurs de ce2 se
sert d'appui tony conte sûrement reçu
des ordres d'aude su peu importe mais il
faudrait les mettre devant leurs
responsabilités devant les tribunaux et
cela en mal d'enfants décédés en fonçant
pas d'une grippe et d'un vomissements
parce que là si vous laissez faire ça
qu'est ce qui se passe vous appelez tous
au boycott mais il a dit guillaume et
mathieu delabi aussi il ya 200 salariés
la plus les transporteurs qui vont
livrer plus les commerciaux plus vous
avez foot mille personnes au chômage
pour un mec qui a donné des orc et payer
lui dix mille balles par mois ou 6020
par mois qui va tout de suite une fois
qu'il est viré de la être recruté par
d'autres chasseurs de têtes parce que
c'est un mec qui a fait de la
rentabilité donc votre entreprise vous
demanderez que voudront le récupérer
pour lui donner ses dix mille balles par
mois mais le mec qui étaient là-bas 1400
balkh a répondu aux ordres lui
retrouvera pas de boulot si facilement
s'il a 50 ans 55 ans une carrière
difficile lui retrouvera pas de boulot
donc là on va condamner des gens à 1400
bas et les mecs à 10000 bas moi
j'aimerais bien qu'ils passent devant
les tribunaux et qui sait ce qu'il va
faire que ça serait bien de la
perquisition au siège
alors eu des directives pour que nos
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent à 21
ans une je vous donnais les cinq
conseils dans l'es5 règle pour éviter au
mieux les intoxications alimentaires en
beaucoup d'intoxication alimentaire
comme celles pour qui a été causé par la
pizza sont codées par la consommation de
produits animaux malcuit consommés crus
mais aussi par des aliments souillés il
est donc important de bien cuire à coeur
la viande surtout si elle est destiné à
de jeunes enfants à des femmes enceintes
et des personnes âgées ou
immunodéprimées il faut faire cuire la
viande et le poisson à 60 degrés minimum
moi je comprends pas c'est que cette
pizza les étaient cuites
voilà donc comment ça se fait c'est soit
une un problème dans la chaîne de froid
soit la présence structurelles de cette
bactérie parce que dans une inspection
la marque dément je le précise mais on a
trouvé cette bactérie là bas donc mais
elle était à cause de problèmes
d'hygiène présente dans l'usiné c'était
avant même la conception de la pizza
pour une question de rentabilité mais
avec bach qui a mille quatre cents
ballots 1500 bahlul intérimaire qui
vient là pour bosser pour faire l'huile
est pour rien on lui dit si t'es pas
content il ya deux portails tu peux
dégager souvient de vous dit ça le mec
qui est le même qui est payé huit mille
balles par mois c'est lui le directeur
qui fait à ce qu'il voit et c'est ce qui
se passe dans son truc c'est lui qui a
donné les cadences c'est lui qui a dit
en 2 minutes vous doivent sortir tant
pizza en trois minutes tu dois sortir et
c'est lui qui doit aller devant un
tribunal et de regarder les juges et
regardé les familles et dire voilà tu
donnes des bons d'achat de 20 euros là
il ya deux décès maintenant tu vas être
toi tu veux être à la barre et peut-être
que ça s'arrête alors peut-être que les
mecs en deux en deux les chéris être
vigilant sur les aliments crus pour
protéger les enfants de moins de cinq
ans plus vulnérables il ne faut pas leur
faire consommer de lait cru ni de
fromages au lait cru ne ne pas leur
faire boire d'eau non traitée venant
depuis par exemple avec les vaches veaux
moutons et chèvres voilà en trois se
laver les mains avant de cuisiner et de
manger ça il faut le faire absolument en
4 bien conserver ses aliments les
concerts bien sûr au frais les produits
traiteur plats cuisinés pâtisseries et
on les consomme trois jours max après
leur achat et enfin soigner son frigo il
faut nettoyer régulièrement son
réfrigérateur on maintient la
température la zone la plus froide entre
0 et 4 degrés mais ça c'est vrai que
c'est ce que font les gens généralement
et là c'est vrai qu'avec cette histoire
on dit alors elle a été réchauffé donc
c'est assez inquiète énormément les
consommateurs énormément alors le
scandale et est très très grave
d'habitude il ya 164 cette bactérie par
an en france et là ils se sont aperçus
qu'ils en avaient un peu partout et si
le scandale n'est pas plus grave c'est
parce que ils ont réussi à détecter avec
les cartes de fidélité des gens les
achats ils ont vu qu'il y avait la
présence de cette pizza exemple ils se
sont dit grâce aux cartes de fidélité
tout le monde sur ses bons à acheter des
pizzas et ils ont pu arrêter alors des
trop tard mais arrêter sinon il y en a
eu des centaines des milliers oui et à
moindre échelle but tony sont résilient
jusqu'en 2017 il avait déjà été épinglée
parce qu'ils avaient vendu des
tortellinis au boeuf est en fait
secteurs qui lient nos cheveux parce que
c'est moins cher donc toujours encore
des problèmes de à méditer mais voilà ce
qu'en 2013 est aujourd'hui un drame
aujourd'hui des drames voilà est
aujourd'hui à des familles qui ont été
brisées parce que leurs enfants à manger
une pizza c'est inadmissible